[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis ravi de vous
retrouver pour un nouveau numéro du 7-8
europe
le dernier de cette année 2018
au programme notamment ce mois ci une
brasserie locale située en seine et
marne la brasserie à pachamama produit
près de 2000 litres de bière par semaine
et son succès ne cesse de s'accroître
depuis ses débuts il ya deux ans et pour
pouvoir tenir le rythme de la demande
ces deux jeunes créateurs ont profité du
soutien financier du fonds européen
agricole pour le développement rural
vingt mille euros en tout pour acheter
de nouvelles cuves c'est l'objet de
notre reportage dès le début de cette
émission
dans la deuxième partie de ce set 8
europe a enregistré au parlement
européen de strasbourg
interview d'alain lamassoure ancien
membre des républicains nous évoquerons
avec lui les élections européennes à
venir mais aussi et surtout des
questions liées à l'évasion et
l'optimisation fiscale
alain lamassoure est membre d'une
commission spéciale sur le sujet au
parlement européen et puis vers la fin
de cette émission nous avons nos rendez
vous habituel avec une date qui a marqué
l'histoire de l'europe et plus
particulièrement l'europe de la défense
ce mois ci et la comparaison européenne
consacrée à la lutte contre le virus du
sida
[Musique]
vous allez sûrement en boire quelques
unes pendant cette période de fin
d'année la bière reste un incontournable
à l'heure notamment de l'apéritif est
désormais à côté des grandes marques
classiques les bières locales ont su se
faire une place
on en dénombre près de mille aujourd'hui
en france paris et sa région n'échappe
pas au phénomène en seine et marne deux
passionnés de la forêt de fontainebleau
ont lancé leur bière locale
il y a deux ans face au succès rencontré
depuis et pour répondre à la demande ils
ont dû faire appel au fonds européen
reportage au coeur de la brasserie à
pachamama il n'y a finalement que le nom
de leurs brasseries référence à une
tradition sud américaine qui n'a pas une
sonorité local sinon boris et sylvain la
sueur ici tout est hommage à la forêt de
fontainebleau et à sa région
fontainebleau le nom de la bière écrit
en deux mots rappel non seulement la
ville mais surtout la forêt qui on a une
grosse communauté de grimpeurs qui
viennent du monde entier en fait dans la
région aux beaux jours pour profiter de
l' escalade et trouve directement les
boissons fait pour leur activité en
rapport avec leur activité
sunbay les états ça correspond à 5
degrés blanche 6° blonde et 7° ombre et
le grimpeur lui d'avoir des niveaux
disque est différent une bière
artisanale avec 50% de grès d'orge
locaux et des attributs sportifs
c'est donc la promesse de cette
brasserie seine et marnaise une
brasserie qui séduit les clients et
professionnelle ouverte il y a deux ans
seulement le succès ne s'est pas fait
attendre
les néo brasseur rendue très rapidement
augmenter les rythmes de production à
l'ouverture de la brasserie on a fait
une fête à l'extérieur et on a vendu
quasiment la totalité des deux mois de
production qu'on avait préalablement
fait en quinze jours de temps donc on a
on avait commencé à brasser sur les
captures qui se trouve derrière moi et
suite à cette ouverture et au succès des
bières mais on a décidé de racheter tout
de suite de nouvelles cuves de deux mois
deux mois après autour du mois de
décembre 2005 janvier 2017 4,6 puis
désormais 12 cuve les litres de bière
comme les capsules s'écoule rapidement
pour faire face à la demande les deux
amis ont dû solliciter le soutien de
fonds européens
une enveloppe de 20 mille euros au total
grâce à laquelle ils ont pu investir
dans du matériel
on a également bénéficié des aides pour
acheter cette grosse machine là qui est
une embouteilleuse donc il va nous
permettre d'en but et y est mis
de bière en trois heures de temps chose
pour laquelle il nous fallait avant dix
à douze heures c'était des journées
interminables clairement si on n'avait
pas eu les fonds européens à ce moment
là on n'aura peut-être pas investi de la
même manière ça nous a permis d'investir
un peu plus rapidement les
investissements réalisés permettent
aujourd'hui à la brasserie pachamama de
produire jusqu'à 2000 litres de bière
par semaine à quelques jours de noël une
nouvelle offre est aussi disponible
un calendrier de la praye l'occasion
d'allier plaisir et locales pendant les
fêtes sans abus bien sûr et les fonds
européens nous allons continuer à en
parler avec notre invité en plateau
françois morton bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes premier adjoint au maire de
guyancourt on a l'habitude dans cette
émission de recevoir des chefs
d'entreprise des entrepreneurs pour pour
parler des fonds européens eux qui ont
bénéficié des fonds européens
mais les collectivités aussi peuvent en
bénéficier votre ville par exemple dans
le cadre de l'accès au numérique et à
l'informatique
si j'ai bien compris guyancourt cherche
à réduire la fracture numérique et
sociale des personnes qui n'ont pas
accès aux outils numériques et
informatiques
oui absolument alors les espaces publics
numériques sur la ville de guyancourt
existe depuis une petite dizaine
d'années ils étaient au nombre de deux
la ferme et dans le quartier des sols et
puis on s'interrogeait sur le projet du
deuxième qui est située dans le quartier
prix de prioritaire du pont du rotois re
et c'est vrai que à l'appel d'offres de
ces fonds européens on a pu présenter un
dossier qui nous a permis à la fois de
pouvoir le financer puisque ce cet
espace public numérique était on va dire
un peu en danger pour des raisons
budgétaires mais surtout de pouvoir
restructurer de retravailler le projet
autour effectivement de de cette
fracture numérique dont on parle parfois
mais qui peut être parfaitement réel sur
certains territoires et donc ça consiste
en quoi concrètement quand on se
présente sur place
quand on assiste à ses ateliers ses
cours là alors il y a plusieurs
modalités
j'ai envie dire d'abord de l'accueil
libre parce que je crois que c'est
important de maintenir cet accueil libre
savais que tout le monde n'est pas au
même niveau 1 face au numérique donc
certains peuvent déjà très autonome et
avoir besoin simplement l'accès
d'équipement et puis d'autres ont besoin
d'être accompagnés d'autres types de
publics d'autres personnes ont besoin
d'être accompagnés nous avons une
personne effectivement qui travaillent à
temps complet sur ce sur l'animation de
cet espace public numérique au travers
d'ateliers thématiques par exemple
autour de démarches administratives
faire beaucoup de choses aujourd'hui se
passe sur internet et surtout que si on
ne maîtrise pas les outils informatiques
et ben ça peut être un cercle vicieux
qui se met en place on n'a pas accès à
allan poe en tout cas c'est souvent
recherché de connaître internet et ses
outils tout à fait je ne sais pas si
vous connaissez ce film de ken loach
mois daniel blake qui était alors certes
ça se passe au royaume uni mais ça
décrivait assez bien ce parcours du
combattant de quelqu'un qui a un vrai
problème par rapport à l'accès au
numérique
effectivement beaucoup de démarches
maintenant se font par l'intermédiaire
du numérique la recherche d'emploi vous
en avez parlé mais tout ce qui est des
marches autour de la caf par exemple
voir pour des parents simplement avoir
le suivi de leurs enfants au collège au
travers d'un certain nombre de logiciels
de suivi de scolarité par exemple et
donc c'est vrai que c'est important de
pouvoir à la fois donner l'accès l'accès
simple j'ai envie de dire aux matériels
mais aussi d'apprendre et d'être formé
est ce que vous avez pu remarquer peut
être à guyancourt un lien entre on va
dire inégalités sociales et cette
fracture numérique est ce que c'est le
même public qui est concerné par les
parler d'eux alors très souvent peut
avoir des représentations alors c'est
vrai que nous sommes situés l'espace
public numérique est situé dans le
quartier prioritaire du pont du routard
et on peut avoir la représentation que
ces disparités peuvent être liés aux
professions au csp et ses termes et ce
n'est pas le seul paramètre le
paramètres d'âge est de plus en plus
important un jeune de 20 ans n'est pas
sensibilisé de la même manière au
numérique que un senior de 70 ans est
évident et pourtant ces personnes ont
encore besoin de faire est de plus en
plus de démarches
on a aussi on peut avoir le paramètre de
genre en fonction de la répartition des
tâches par exemple au sein de la cellule
familiale on peut avoir effectivement
des disparités entre hommes et femmes
et donc c'est aussi un moyen
effectivement d'aller 2
d'amenuiser un petit peu d'amoindrir un
petit peu ces inégalités donc ça
concerne tout le monde ça peut aider
tout le monde et ce jusqu'au 31 décembre
merci françois morton d'être venu sur
notre plateau d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes le
premier adjoint au maire de guyancourt
merci on reste dans cette thématique
numérique et en europe avec la liste des
lauréats du programme de la commission
européenne
wii fit for you huit communes d'île de
france vont en bénéficier dans celle de
rochefort en yvelines ce programme vise
à aider financièrement ces communes a
installé des accès wifi dans leurs
bâtiments et espaces publics chacune
d'entre elles devraient percevoir
jusqu'à à 15000 euros au titre de
l'année 2018 le programme sera reconduit
en 2019
on passe à présent à la deuxième partie
de cette émission vous en avez
l'habitude elle est enregistrée au
parlement européen notre invité pour
l'interview politique est alain
lamassoure membres de la droite
européenne et spécialiste des questions
liées à l'optimisation et l'évasion
fiscale les scandales ne manquent pas en
europe depuis quelques années luc slicks
panama peppers ou encore paradise papers
pour ne citer qu'eux
[Musique]
depuis le parlement européen de
strasbourg nous sommes maintenant avec
alain lamassoure bonsoir bonsoir
eurodéputés d'île de france vous êtes
membre du ppe le parti populaire
européen on va dire la droite européenne
pour schématiser vous avez confirmé
récemment que vous ne serez pas candidat
en mai prochain aux élections après 24
ans de mandat en qualité d'eurodéputé
pourquoi une telle décision est ce qu'il
ya une usure psychologique et
intellectuel après presque 25 ans passés
ici je ne dirais pas usurpée il ya la
loi de la vie il ya un moment où il faut
savoir passer le flambeau à la jeune
génération et je compte là la jeune la
très jeune génération est très très
européenne moi j'appartiens à une
génération qui est née à la fin de la
guerre et qui est qu'il y avait un
attachement affectif considérable
vis-à-vis du projet européen de la
construction européenne parce que
l'europe ça voulait dire la
réconciliation franco-allemande la paix
donc ça méritait qu'on y consacre sa vie
la génération des 15 cas aujourd'hui ils
n'ont pas le même attachement affectif
par contre leurs enfants la génération
qui avait un 25 ans maintenant c'est les
enfants erasmus c'est la génération
erasmus c'est le 21e siècle il découvre
que pour profiter des formidables
opportunités de ce siècle et notamment
les nouvelles technologies
le nouvel art de vivre et puis faire
face au formidable danger de ce siècle
il faut oublier en europe
ou bien on est européen où on l'est pas
et donc ils se sentent à nouveau
européen et donc savoir faire et laisser
la place aux jeunes votre nouvelle vie
doit quand vous menez notamment à
occuper un observatoire de
l'enseignement de l'histoire de l'europe
est-ce que vous avez des des précisions
là dessus de quoi ça leur at-il c'est
encore un projet c'est un sujet très
délicat
ces deux compétences chaque pays chaque
pays en scène l'histoire qu'il veut
comme il veut
à ses enfants mais nous partageons des
valeurs communes
nous partageons la charte européenne des
droits fondamentaux nous sommes des
démocraties nous sommes des états de
droit et grâce au projet européen nous
avons réconcilier nos pays et nous
devons éviter à tout prix après avoir
réaliser ce miracle qui est la
réconciliation tout le pays on a eu et a
encore quelques semaines des images
émouvantes
à l'occasion de la commémoration de
l'armistice ça serait quand même fou que
deux
nous formions dans nos collèges et nos
lycées une nouvelle génération de
nationalistes or si on assiste depuis
quelques années à une résurgence du
discours de haine
c'est parce qu'on rentre dans l'ordre
assez l'histoire ou en tout cas mal
c'est parce que en effet dans certains
pays on ne raconte pas c'est l'histoire
dans d'autres on raconte une histoire
qui est une propagande nationaliste
ça c'est pour on va dire les citoyens de
demain revenons pour être au présent
avec cette histoire européenne
on a l'impression vous qui est
eurodéputé depuis depuis 25 ans je le
disais presque 25 ans a connu la chute
du mur de berlin toutes les évolutions
du vieux continent aujourd'hui on a
l'impression que l'europe est sur le
mode
retour en arrière monter des
nationalistes des partis eurosceptiques
un de ses membres qui va qui va qui va
quitter le navire si je puis me
permettre
si vous êtes d'accord avec ce sentiment
là que l'europe recul aujourd'hui que
l'idée européenne recule ou alors que
c'est une crise passagère et qu'il faut
se serrer les coudes et attendre que ça
passe
le besoin d'europe est de plus en plus
partagée par les citoyens européens
malgré la montée des partis qui
critiquent à l'europe où il y monte mais
ils sont minoritaires partout et vous
savez en france fondateur de montée
pourrait être majoritaire aux prochaines
élections non vous n'y croyez en aucun
cas
en aucun cas il faut bien voir que
paradoxalement les citoyens européens
sont en majorité beaucoup plus européen
que leurs dirigeants nationaux ce petit
bloc aujourd'hui progrès de l'europe
c'est que les dirigeants nationaux ne
veulent pas franchir le pas je voudrais
que ça à faire de leurs pouvoirs confiés
aux joints exemple le problème
migratoire
bon ça fait des années que je dis le
seul moyen de maîtriser à peu près les
flux migratoires qui vont continuer ça
va être une caractéristique du 21e
siècle
parce que nous assistons une formidable
explosion démographique en l'afrique et
le taux de croissance de l'afrique ne
peut pas suivre le taux de natalité
si nous voulons maîtriser cela maîtriser
ce phénomène en avoir les avantages et
les inconvénients
nous ne pouvons le faire qu'à l'échelle
européenne
c'est une évidence cette évidence est
partagé par 90 % des citoyens
sauf que nous avons des partis
xénophobes ou nationalistes parfois
raciste qui systématiquement s'oppose à
tout ce que fait l'europe parce que
c'est l'europe hockey et nous avons des
citoyens qui sont tout à fait favorables
qui sont tout à fait conscients mais des
dirigeants qui voudraient avoir le
beurre et l'argent du beurre c'est à
dire que oui on voit bien que pour être
efficace il faut que l'europe s'en mêle
mais je ne veux pas que ce soit des
policiers européens derniers européens
qui gardent mais frontières à moi il ya
un moment où il va falloir franchir le
pas et je dirais que de ce point de vue
l'année qui vient et les résultats des
élections européennes qui viennent
seront déterminants
la problématique c'est aussi que les
élections européennes n'attire pas les
foules on le sait l'abstention c'est 60%
moigne qu'est ce que vous diriez vous
rapidement par exemple avec votre
expérience pour pousser les électeurs de
du mois de mai à ceux à se déplacer et
aller voter mais moi je crois qu'ils
sont six européens que ça tout
simplement c'est vous qui allez décider
du choix de monsieur ou une madame euros
par son émission ne sera mesurée
maintenant leur équipe y avoir en tête
des élections européennes mettra son sa
tête de liste en tant que président de
la commission européenne du helmand
c'est ce qui s'est passé la dernière
fois mais à part tv 78 aucun grand média
national de l'adie en france et donc les
français ne savent pas que le président
de la commission européenne aujourd'hui
monsieur europe disons jean claude
juncker
jean claude juncker c'est eux qui l'ont
élu mais cette fois ci je crois que ça
se présente sous de meilleurs auspices
le parti populaire européen à et en
allemand a élu votre avis aux gamers un
fan webber
il est le président du groupe
parlementaire du ppe au parlement de
strasbourg c'est un bon parlementaire
c'est un homme qui le gêne qui à 46 ans
il n'a pas d'expérience gouvernementale
mais c'est pas un problème ça selon vous
pour on dirige
on va vers le il vaut mieux vaut dans le
cadre de livres mieux quelqu'un qui est
effectivement une expérience puis
monsieur webber n'est pas moi le plus
très mais très bavard on va dire devant
les médias mais quelques pas les
socialistes où il sera bon dans les
médias sur 24 pas les socialistes ont
eux mêmes choisi monsieur timmerman ce
qui est actuellement le premier vice
président de commission qui est un
ancien mise affaires étrangères
néerlandais
polyglotte très très remarquable bon les
centristes et les verts choisiront peut
plus faire leur candidat
si on continue à parler du présent et
montrer l'importance aussi de l'or pur
c'est pour ces élections européennes
prenons le un sujet qui vous vous a
beaucoup occupé sur la dernière
mandature sur cette mandature c'est la
fiscalité dans le sillage des
différentes des différents scandales luc
slicks paradise papers panama papers
l'europe le parlement européen s'est
saisi de ces sujets là est ce que vous
diriez quand quatre ou cinq ans vous en
avez assez fait qu'aujourd'hui on a un
système qui permet d'éviter efficacement
l'évasion fiscale non non moi j'aurais
pu faire un argument pour les élections
européennes
oui ben moi c'est oui oui non non on n'a
pas assez fait si votre question est
effacée non on n'a pas assez fait mais
en quatre ans on a fait la pub fait
avancer quand on consacre 40 ans oui
c'est clair
pourquoi parce que les sujets fiscaux ça
reste de compétences nationales l'union
européenne le peinte et revenir que s'il
ya des dispositions fiscales dans un
pays qui peuvent fausser le grand marché
au bénéfice des acteurs du pays concerné
c'est le cas et c'est là que les
scandales sont utiles pour
malheureusement magique dans des
périodes de crise où vous face à des
scandales c'est le cas en ce qui
concerne l'imposition des entreprises
notamment des multinationales parce
qu'il est apparu qu'avec la
mondialisation de l'économie
les multinationales profiter des
différences de fiscalité notamment
l'intérieur d' union européenne pour
échapper à la quasi-totalité de
l'imposition pour les bénéfices qu'ils
réalisent en dehors des états-unis ou en
dehors de leur état de naissance si je
figure alors le parlement européen en
bonne coopération avec la commission
européenne le commissaire moscovici et
l' ocde a mis en place une commission
denquête que j'ai présidé fait des
propositions rendant obligatoire la
l'information mutuelle des
administrations fiscales des états
membres sur la façon dont les
multinationales sont imposés dans chacun
des états membres et surtout travailler
sur une proposition de d'impôt sur les
sociétés qui serait un impôt européen
des finissants de la même manière dans
tous les pays pour tous les secteurs
économiques pour toutes les tailles
d'entreprises ce qu est un bénéfice
imposable laissant à chaque état la
possibilité de mettre le taux qu'il veut
sur cet impôt qui serait identique et je
regrette que cette proposition
n'ai pas été en tête des priorités de la
france en a fait mais peut-être pas
assez on a raison c'est à dire que vous
avez engagé le processus mais nous
n'arriverons pas à lutter efficacement
contre ces tentatives d'évasion dit elle
c'est pas de la fraude et d'évasion
c'est d'évaporation fiscal que si nous
avons le même système dans les 27 pays
européens
alain lamassoure rester avec nous on va
continuer à parler d'histoire avec notre
rubrique ce jour là on se penchera aussi
sur le 3 et 4 décembre 1998 à saint malo
en bretagne un sommet franco-britannique
a servi à poser les bases de la
politique de défense européenne c'est ce
que nous précise philippe le guen
coordinateur adjoint pour le parlement
européen de la maison jean monnet basée
à bazoches sur guyonne dans les yvelines
c'est un sommet dans le cadre de la
présidence française à l'époque de de
l'europe
c'est sous la présidence de jacques
chirac sont le premier ministre
britannique tony blair et là on commence
dans le prolongement de de la politique
européenne de sécurité et de défense
on commence à concrètement regarder des
deux pays la grande bretagne et la
france
si finalement on n'est pas prêt à
évoluer sur sur les questions de défense
c'est à dire que la france serait mans
s'en acquitter sa politique un petit peu
qui lui est propre
depuis le général de gaulle les
britanniques
amorçant aussi un rapprochement vers
l'europe alors c'est qu'un début 1 c'est
ça mais c'est une étape importante
d'ailleurs c'est c'est une étape que qui
va peut-être aussi redevenir dans
l'actualité avec le la question du break
site puisque si les britanniques
quittent l'union européenne en tout cas
en niveau de défense la grande bretagne
et la france sont quand même les pays
qui est qui ont le plus les plus grandes
armées et les peler les armements les
plus modernes et
les budgets les plus importants en terme
de défense donc là aussi il y aura des
des nouveaux accords a trouvé pour que
les britanniques restent arrimés à
l'europe
au niveau de la défense commune puisque
entre temps en plus d'autres menaces
sont sont intervenus par rapport à
l'époque du traité de saint malo on s
des accords de saint malo on est
maintenant sur le thé sur les menaces
que vous qu on connait tous terroristes
en particulier des menaces beaucoup plus
globale des menaces aussi qui touche la
sécurité informatique
tout cela était balbutiant à l'époque et
on voit bien aujourd'hui qu'il faut une
réponse globale européenne pour le moins
pour pouvoir faire face à ces menaces
donc il est évident que ce qui a été
initié à l'époque ans un à saint malo
redevient plus que jamais d'actualité
aujourd'hui dans un nouveau contexte
européen
une question encore alain lamassoure sur
cette actualité l'armée européenne qui
est revenu dans le débat politique
emmanuel macron en a parlé un gala
merkel a soutenu aussi a semblé soutenir
cette idée est ce que vous y croyez
aussi là dessus et est ce que c'est un
c'est une thématique important
réellement aujourd'hui pour l'union
européenne
oui bien sûr là aussi c'est un sujet sur
lequel les citoyens sont beaucoup plus
européen que leurs dirigeants
quand dans le cadre des sondages
périodiques que l'on fait qu'on appelle
les eurobaromètre on demande aux
français à votre avis quels sont les
sujets qui désormais doivent être
traités au niveau européen ou continuer
d'être traitée au niveau national
80% des français citent la politique
étrangère la défense comme devant
désormais traités au niveau européen
c'est du bon sens là aussi c'est une
question de souveraineté et notamment
pour la france de lâcher son va dire sa
mainmise sur la politique étrangère
nomique européenne presque jamais de
dire que signifie le mot de souveraineté
au 21ème siècle
est ce que en adoptant l'euro nous avons
perdu notre souveraineté
non nous participe c'est ce que pensent
certains doutes oui mais s'il n'en avait
pas fait ça et bien nous serions soumis
à la politique monétaire de l'allemagne
que la france sera obligée de suivre
simplement le point sur lequel joue
d'insister c'est que une europe de la
défense
oui bien sûr
on commence à mettre en place le début
de quelque chose qui ressemble à une
heure de la défense mais on n'a pas un
outil militaire pur plaisir d'avoir de
faire défiler des soldats le 14 juillet
ou le 9 mai non c'est pour appuyer une
politique étrangère commune et je suis
très surpris que la france n'ait pas
pris l'initiative de proposer une
politique étrangère commune en annonçant
par exemple que elle mettait à la
disposition de l'union européenne son
vote au conseil de sécurité de l'onu
depuis le départ était un signe
employeurs ni oui ni ville départ du
royaume uni la france est le seul pays
membres l'union européenne qui membres
permanents du conseil de sécurité avec
droit de veto sur vision de conseiller
sécurité
on terminera cette interview là dessus
merci alain lamassoure d'avoir répondu à
toutes nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes membre du parti populaire
européen eurodéputés d'île de france
merci
le 1er décembre dernier c'était la
journée mondiale de lutte contre le sida
un virus encore présents en europe et
qui continuent de propager notamment de
se propager en europe de l'est c'est
l'objet de notre rubrique chez nos
voisins ça se passe comment avec olivier
janot x d'europe direct à saint germain
en laye donc selon le dernier rapport de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé oms
n'a constaté sur l'année 2016 2017 une
augmentation de 160 me cas de personnes
infectées par le vih
on a constaté que la hausse la plus
importante
en termes de nombre de personnes
affectées par le vih en fête a eu lieu
en estonie où on a eu plus 365 cas de
personnes affectées est le pays le moins
touché c'est la slovaquie avec une
augmentation seulement de 87 cas les
pays de l'union européenne ont mis en
place différentes initiatives que ce
soit pour faire de la prévention ou pour
lutter concrètement contre la maladie
on peut prendre le cas par exemple de
l'estonie qui a décidé d'injecter 20
millions d'euros dans sa politique de
santé afin d'améliorer la prise en
charge financière notamment pour l'achat
des médicaments pour les personnes qui
ce qu'ils souhaitent bénéficier d'une
trithérapie
si on prend le cas de la france alors là
au niveau de la france ont davantage
agir sur ce qui est la prévention
notamment avec de la mise à disposition
gratuite de préservatifs pour les jeunes
de moins de moins de 25 ans il existe
aussi d'autres formes de prévention par
exemple au niveau du royaume uni
on a constaté ces dernières années en
fait une augmentation du nombre de bus
itinérant qui se déplace de ville en
ville afin d'organiser des tests de
dépistage au sein des villes pour les
personnes qui passent c'est la fin de ce
set 8 europe merci aux équipes du
parlement pour la réalisation de cet
entretien on se retrouve en 2019 pour un
nouveau numéro du 7-8 europe d'ici là
vous retrouvez cette émission replay sur
tv et 78 points comme ou l'application
tv 78 merci beaucoup et 22 soirée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]